more than three decades after taking
down the New York Mafia Rudy Guiliani
America's mayor is back in the spotlight
working as president Trump's personal
attorney he's using the same shark-like
skills from his mob days to try to
shield Trump from Robert Muller's
investigation Donald Trump and Rudy
Giuliani have one major trait in common
I think their styles are very similar in
that they seek attention they both have
this New York brashness to them that's
Shannon petty piece and I'm a White
House reporter with Bloomberg News Trump
appointed Giuliani as his personal
attorney on April 19 within 48 hours
Giuliani went on an all-out media blitz
he started contradicting himself quite
quickly having having something to do
with paying some stormy Daniels woman
130,000 I mean which is gonna turn out
to be perfectly legal that money was not
campaign money sorry I'm giving you a
fact now that you don't know Giuliani
went on television time and time again
and made mistake after mistake that
ended up just embarrassing the president
more than anything else that's Andrew
Kurtzman who literally wrote the book on
Giuliani funneled through law firm and
the president repaid oh I didn't know he
did there's no campaign finance law
and I think it was less than 48 hours
later I had to put out a statement
trying to clarify what he was saying
because his comments had created even
more confusion
so while Giuliani's tenure got off to a
rocky start why did Trump even pick him
to be his lawyer in the first place
well Giuliani has a lot of experience
with the Justice Department and there
were a number of lawyers who were more
suited to deal with the type of
investigation like this who basically
turned the president down because of
conflicts or concerns about what would
happened to their reputation for working
for this controversial president so then
what does Giuliani actually bring to the
table Giuliani was brought on as much to
be Trump's lawyer as to be Trump
confident
he is someone that the president trusts
and that can communicate with the
president in a clear straight way that
he'll understand and this trust comes
from decades of Trump and Giuliani
running in New York circles when you
know Giuliani was with the Justice
Department in New York he was there as a
very high-profile prosecutor and Donald
Trump was in New York as a very
high-profile businessman and real estate
developer they both inhabited the same
world that world was New York City in
the 70s and 80s in 1983 Giuliani became
the Manhattan US Attorney who took on
the mob and he did so in an extremely
public way holding press conference
after press conference in what was up
until that point a very press shy job he
was a type of prosecutor who was on the
cover of newspapers and the cover of
magazines and you know there's the old
saying that the most dangerous place to
be was between Rudy Giuliani at a
microphone on November 20th 1986
Giuliani won the conviction of all eight
defendants in the massive Mafia
Commission trial and then in 1993 he
became the first Republican mayor of New
York since 1965 he ran on the platform
of reform and reducing crime and he
delivered in the early 90s New York was
crime ridden with a dwindling middle
class by the millennium violent crime in
the city dropped 56% however by the end
of his second term his polls were
lagging and his legacy was about to be
the mayor who cleaned up New York City
but then so this looks like it is some
sort of a concerted to attack the World
Trade Center and that's when he moved
from the Daily News New York Post cover
famous to being a famous figure across
America
the Time magazine's Person of the Year
he was a natural presidential contender
so he decided to run for president I
believe we can hand our nation to the
next generation better than it was
handed to us and the 2008 GOP nomination
was there for the taking
I mean he was far in a way more popular
and also better known than his
Republican editors as a result of 9/11
but he made some catastrophic campaign
decisions and there was also his 9/11
problem Joe Biden had one of the best
lines of the campaign when he said Rudy
Giuliani there's two there's only three
things he mentions a sentence and now in
the Bourbon 9/11 I mean there's nothing
out Giuliani's poll numbers plummeted
and he didn't secure a single state for
the GOP nomination his political career
was wrecked and so he you know went back
into kind of private practice but
basically he was out of the action but
in 2016 an opportunity Leon II hitched
his wagon to the Trump train and while
he was passed over for multiple cabinet
positions when Trump became president
being appointed his Trump's counsel has
thrust him back into the spotlight but
no matter what may happen from here it
probably won't really affect his true
legacy I think the most memorable image
of him will always be in America's minds
in those days after 9/11 he's a person
who you know took on the mob and had
extraordinary results and then helped
turn around New York City and then led
America really through its worst crisis
I mean that those are accomplishments of
a lifetime
you